- [David] Hello, readers.
Today it is a time for action.
(horn blares)
Yes, sound the horn of action,
because today we're
going to be talking about
character actions in stories.
Understanding what characters do
is key to your success as a reader.
The way characters behave
towards themselves,
towards others, towards objects,
can tell us a lot about them
and can give us clues to the
larger messages in a story.
Character actions are what
drive a story forward.
Let my co-worker Kim read you a story
in which nobody takes any actions.
- [Kim] Once upon a time,
there was a magical kingdom
in which nobody ever did anything.
Nobody baked bread or called
their friends on the phone
or played video games
or soccer or basketball
or wrote books or ate yogurt.
They didn't even nap.
They just sat there.
(Kim yawns)
It was a very boring kingdom.
- [David] Why, thank you, Kim.
Without character action,
there is no story.
Let's try that again.
I'll blow the horn of action
and Kim you do that again,
but this time let's throw
in some character decisions.
All right, lights, camera, horn of action.
(horn blares)
- [Kim] The magical kingdom of Belchantry
was abuzz with activity.
Bakers baked, ballers shot hoops,
yogurt smiths made yogurt.
The young princess Lulabell
practiced her swordplay.
And on a great tower on
the outskirts of town
an evil wizard put the
finishing touches on a spell
that would bring terrible
darkness to the land.
- [David] See, now that's
a story I wanna hear.
Character actions and decisions
have to drive the story.
It's about what characters choose to do,
not just about the world around them.
There could be a big, scary storm,
but that's not character action.
It's about how the
characters react to the storm
that matters, that shapes the story.
What do characters do in times of trouble
or when their friends need help?
That's when you can learn
the most about them.
Actions speak louder
than words, after all.
What motivates these characters?
Why do they act the way they act?
What are the values or
beliefs that drive them?
What are their goals?
And what does that tell us
about the message of the story?
Sometimes characters don't
behave in the way that we expect,
like villainous characters may seem nice
in order to do evil things.
If we think about "The Three Little Pigs."
If the Big Bad Wolf is going
door to door and saying,
"Hello, little pig.
"It's me, your new neighbor,
the Small Nice Wolf.
"And I brought you some cookies."
If you're the pig looking out the window,
you should open the door, right?
Heek no!
The wolf is trying to
trick you, lock the door.
What's interesting about
looking at character actions
is they can help us see
how characters change
throughout a story.
In the film "Moana,"
the demi-god character Maui
begins as a selfish tricky character,
but by the end of the movie he's changed
and he cares about Moana and helps her.
We can see that because of his actions.
He begins by stealing Moana's boat
and stranding her on an island,
and he ends by sacrificing his
magic fish hook to help her.
Sorry for "Moana" spoilers.
Characters in stories can be
complex, just like real people.
The way they behave might surprise you.
And if it does, ask yourself,
why is this a surprise?
Why is this character
behaving in this way?
Look for evidence throughout a text
to help you understand
the way characters act.
If you've insight into
their thoughts or feelings,
that can be a great place to start.
But, for now, I'm going to take
action by ending this video.
You can learn anything, David out.